e herkese merhaba ben Şenay Gürler beni
bir parça olsun tanıyorsunuz sizlerle
kadına şiddet hakkında konuşacağım
Gönlüm isterdi ki aynı ortamda olalım
bensiz görebileyim sizin istediğim
enerjinizi alayım karşılıklı
konuşabilirim ama maalesef Ben de bu
koşullarda Bu mümkün değil Ne yapalım
bugünler de geçecek daha iyi daha güzel
günlerimiz olacak diye ediyorum kadına
şimdi hakkında konuşacağız şimdi sadece
fiziksel şiddetten bahsetmiyorum şiddet
fiziksel cinsel psikolojik sözel baskı
ve zorlayıcı lık içeren bir kavram Bu da
öncelikle kadınları bir soru sormak
istiyorum şöyle bir hayatınız düşünün
satılık ederseniz kadar geri gittim hiç
Hayatınız boyunca bu şiddet türlerinden
herhangi birini birebir yaşadığınız
bu kadınların güzel 97'si malesef evet
diyecek zaten yüzden olmuştu erkeklerin
yüzde yüzü Tanık olmuştur Umarım
uygulamışlardır Belki de hayatımı
baktığımda Ben bu şekilde türlerin
hepsini birebir yaşanır maalesef acı
gerçek Bu sadece Türkiye'nin sorunu
değil Bu arada tüm dünyanın Ama tabii ki
topraklarda yaşıyoruz ve bu
topraklardaki kadınların sorunlarını
daha yakından biliyoruz şiddetlerde
başlıyor Önce nerede başlıyor işte önce
ay içinde başlıyor aile içi ve
çevresinde başlıyor kız çocuklarını
okula göndermek istemiyor ilkokula
gittikten sonra ona genellikle söz
ediyorum Yalnız genellikle içmiş Birol
var kız çocuğu evlendirilecek bir
evlilik yapacak bir Eş iyi bir anne
olacak bunlar hiçbir sorun yok tabii ki
kadın iyi bir eş olsun iyi bir anne
olsun ama kadının başka alanlarda
mı başka şekillerde var olma halinin
engellenmesi söz konusu başka bir
şekilde bağlı olabileceği düşünülüyor
bile kadın ve düşündürür müydü öyle
getiriyoruz çocuklarımızı bu diyelim ki
kız çocuğu Aile içerisinde cinsel bir
tacize uğrar bu ya kabullenmiyor bile
bile getirilmiyor bu durumda
düzleştirmiyor ki Ben çevremde bunun
örneklerini çok gördüm Çok yakın
arkadaşlarımın ve çocukların da bu tür
şeyleri yaşadıklarını annelerine ya da
yakınlarını anlattıklarında bunu
üzülmediğini kız çocuğunun yazıldığını
yanlış anladığını bunun yüzleşmesi zaten
korkunç en büyük sorunlarımızdan biri
durumla yüzleşmek üzerine örtmek diyelim
ki yüz yeşildi buradan namus cinayetleri
ne yapıyor ve yine Bunun sorumlusu kız
çocuğu görülüyor kız çocuğunu öldürüyor
ya da kız çocuğu diyelim gideceğimize
uğradı Ne yapıyor tecavüzcüsüyle
evlendirilen bilir Biz da dile
getirilebiliyor meşrulaştırmaya biliyor
bu gerçekten kabul edilebilir bir şey
değil Yine diyelim ki kız çocuğu hani
bütün bunları yaşamadı açtık ip 72 de
işine işe başlayacak bu işe başlarken de
giyme genellikle kocadan ya da babadan
Eğer evdeyse babadan icazet alınıyor
diyelim ki icazeti alındı ya da hiç
icazet olması gerek kalmadı kadın Ben
burada çalışacağım dedi başladı İşe Bu
sefer de iş yerinde at Daha alt
kademelerde erkeklere göre daha alt
kademelerden ve daha az ücretli işe
giriyor son zamanlarda bu değişecek
Bu yıl daha doğrusu ve değişmeye devam
edecek çünkü Çünkü kadınlar artık
susuyorlar kadınlar dertlerini dile
Getiriyorlar bir takım sorunlar da
Bunlar konuşuluyor sosyal medyanın
etkisi oluyor bu sosyal medyayla ilgili
zaten konuşacağız Yani yaratılan
gündemle ilgili konuşacağız Bütün
bunların dışında ve şöyle bir durum var
kamusal alan ve özel alan ayrımı mı
kamusal alanda Tamam bir takım yasalar
var birtakım kurallar var fakat özel
alana girdiğimizde kadını koruyacak
duruma devlet ve toplum mesafeli
yaklaşıyor yani Öf o onların arasında
kadın-erkek ilişkisine karşımıza ile
içinden Size diyorum karı-koca ilişkisi
ne karışmaz hocası döverdi severdi bunu
dilimize yerleşmiştir burada devletin
daha bağlayıcı kararlar alıp uygulaması
gerekiyor Yani bu son dönemlerde çok
dile getiriliyor
bu adımlar atıldı Tabii ki daha da
atılması gerekiyor ama hala bunun bir
takım şeylerini hep birlikte görüyoruz
okuyoruz konuşuyoruz
Bu aile içindeki şiddette karışmaması
diyelim ki kadın Ben şiddet görüyorum
öldürebilirim diyor yediriyor şikayet
ediyor ve Maalesef bu tutanak tutuluyor
Belki o kadar ama karışmıyor ve kadın
öldürülüyor
ya Neyse sizi biraz Sinirim bozuluyor
insanın bir şey var Bu yıl 269 kadın
öldürdü iki gün önce okudum Şimdi bu
arada birkaç kişi daha eklenmiş olabilir
birkaç kadınlar eklenmiş olabilir 269
kadın ver yılda Bunlar bilinenler Bir de
şüpheli bölümler var şüpheli ölümler ön
kadınlar şikayet etmelerine rağmen
kendilerine koruma a istemelerine rağmen
korunmadığı için ve devletin bu konuda
adımlar atması gerekiyor sosyal medyanın
bu konuda ve Kadın Platformu sivil
toplum örgütlerinin adımlar atması
gerekiyor Bir de değil var Yani değil bu
kadar önemli ki dilimizde de oturmuş
olan şeylerdir kültürümüzün bir parçası
yani parçası kültürümüzün vazgeçilmez
parçası dilde başlıyor atasözlerinde
kadını çocuklarını aşağı
bir şeyler var nedir ilk akla gelenler
ver kadın dişi köpek kuyruğunu
sallamazsa erkek köpek peşinden gitmez
elinin hamuruyla erkek işine karışma
o kadının sırtından sopayı karnından
sıpayı eksik etmeyeceksin bu gibi bunun
gibi daha böyle bir sürü dilimize
oturmuş sözler var deyimler var kadının
hep aşağılayan ötekileştiren Bütün
bunların yanında bizim farkında olmadan
kullandığımız kelimeler var bir çok
önemli diyorum ya haksız yere dövdü
haksız yere vurdu haksız yere öldürüldü
mü haklı olsa beni dönecek mi haklı olsa
bunu vurabilir mi Hayır bir çubuk bu
dile Bu dikkat etmemiz gerekiyor
hepimizin kadın erkek dilimize dikkat
etmemiz gerekiyor Bu sadece kadın erkek
ilişkisini genel olarak toplumda böyle
yanlış kullandığımız o kadar çok şey var
ki
ama gerçekten çok dikkat etmek gerekiyor
dile için ne yapacağız Nasıl bütün bu
durumlardan kurtulacağız ne yapmamız
gerekiyor dediğim gibi gerçekten burada
devletin çok ciddi adımlar atması
gerekiyor sivil toplum örgütlerinin
kadın örgütlenmelerinin yaptığı bir sürü
şimdi var bir sürü faaliyet var sivil
toplum örgütlerinin bu konuda daha
kendilerini dile getirebilmeleri için
alanlar açılması gerekiyor Şu arada
mesela son dönemde kadın cinayetlerinde
konuşuruz hepimizin aklında olan isimler
var Münevver Karabulut aklıma gelenler
Şule çet cinayeti mesaj cinayetiyle
ilgili gerçekten bir günden oluşturulma
saydı sosyal medyada ne olacaktı
kararlar çok merak ediyorum
bu ne kadar mücadele edildi Şule çet
cinayeti ile ilgili ve ancak o zaman
mahkum edildi bu insanlar sonra aklıma
geleni Peker cinayettir daha Aleyna
Çakır hala Bunlar sonuçlanmış olan
davalarda Nadire kadirova kapatıldığı
dosyası kapatıldı Gülistan doku hâlâ
bulunamadığı Duygu delen Pınar Gültekin
cinayetim ise bu cinayetlerde şöyle bir
durumda var farkındaysanız erkek
öldürüyor yakınları akrabaları ki bu
Umarım anneleri de dahil olmak üzere
çocuklarını koruyucu bir şekilde
davranıyorlar yani kızda işte şöyle
giymeseydi işi kız da ona Gitmeseydi O
kadın da buna bunu yapmasaydın bütün
bunları tahrik edici öldürmeye tahrik
edici şeyler olarak görüyorlar vemâ
Bu da böyle değerlendiriyor bir takım
kararlar da böyle değerlendiriyor iyi
halden bırakılıyor İyi halde ne Pardon
indirim yapılıyor cezasında bunları
Tanık oluyoruz aydınlatılmamış o kadar
çok cinayet vardı o yüzden kadın
örgütlenmelerinin çok çok önemli
olduğunu düşünüyorum kadınların bir
araya gelmesinin bir takım sorunlar var
o platformlarda susmadan bir dertlerini
anlatan bilmelerini gerçekten çok önemli
Susma yani zaten biliyorsunuz ve bir şey
başladı Hani metal başladı önce biraz
magazinel bir şeyle başladı belki ama
herkes Allah durumu Bu Türkiye'de bir
parça yansıdı daha sonra birtakım
hareketler yine devam etti dünya
genelindeki şeylerin yansıması ve sağ
son dönemde olduğu için söz etmek
istiyorum kolonyada kadınların kürtaj
hakkı ile ilgili sakın yasalar çıkarmaya
Bu kadınlar direndiler gerçekten çok
büyük bir direniş gösterdiler rap
attılar yasayı durdurdular yani kadınlar
güçlü olduklarının birlikte olurlarsa
daha güçlü olduklarının farkına
varmaları gerekiyor Biz Kadınlar
birbiriniz Bizim kendi hayatımız var ben
tek başıma hayatta var olabilirim bir
erkekle Aynı yolda yürümek Tabii ki çok
değerli evlilikte çok değerli Ama ben
herkesi önce bir kadınım vereyim hayatım
Biricik ben bu hayatı kendim biçimlendir
edeceğim biriyle de birlikte yürüyebilir
Sen ne kadar güzel hareketlerinde bu
konuda yardımcı olmaları gerekiyor Biz
annelerin kız çocuklarını da
yetiştirirken erkek çocuklarını da
yetiştirirken ben tabi anne olarak
söylüyorum onlara şunu anlatmalıyız Sen
bir bireysin ve cinsel kimliğin hiçbir
önemi yok ister kadın o ister
Sağ ol ya da ister başka bir cinsel
kimlikle yaşa bunun hiçbir önemi yok
sadece insan var bir hayat var Orada
nasıl davranılmasını istiyorsan ben de o
insanları öyle davrandım 41 cin hiçbir
ayrım hiçbir cinsel ayrım gözetmeksizin
yaklaşabilme liyim bu insan olmanın
önemli kurallarından bence zaten insan
olmak yolunda çok önemli adımlar Bunlar
Evet böyle bunlardan buluşunca açıkçası
biraz böyle öfkeleniyorum biraz coş
kullanıyorum ama susmayacağız dile
getireceğiz anlatacağız biz bu mücadele
içerisinde erkeklerle bir arada yürümek
istiyoruz Erkeklerin hepsi yanımızda yer
alması bizlerle yürümesi gerçekten
önemli burada son dönemde tartışılan bir
şey var Onu da Dile getirmek istiyorum
kadın haklarıyla ilgili son dönem
değil gündemde olan bir şey bu İstanbul
sözleşmesi İstanbul sözleşmesi Aslında
şöyle bir şey ben bunu Tamam okumak
istiyorum kadına yönelik şiddet ve aile
içi şiddetin önlenmesi ve bunlarla
mücadele edilmesine ilişkin Avrupa
Konseyi sözleşmesi yani namı diğer
İstanbul sözleşmesi kilit Bizim de
burada imzamız var Ama tam olarak
uygulanıyor mu Yok maalesef
uygulanmasıyla ilgili son dönemde çok
tartışma yapıldı Ben İzninizle Bir
maddeyi okumak istiyorum bir kısaca çok
çok önemli olduğunu düşünüyorum temel
haklar madde dördü okuyorum temel haklar
eşitlik ve ayrımcılık yapılmaması
tarafta taraflar herkesin Özellikle de
kadınların gerek kamu gerekse özel
alanda şiddete maruz kalmaksızın yaşama
hakkını yaygınlaştırmak ve korumak için
gerekli olan yasal ve diğer tedbirleri
alacaklardır iki taraflar kadınlara
karşı
her türlü ayrımcılığı kılınacak ve
ayrımcılığı önlemek üzere özellikle
Aşağıdakiler dahil olmak üzere gerekli
yasal ve diğer tedbirleri alacaklardır
Bunlar neler ulusal anayasalarında veya
ilgili diğer mevzuata kadın erkek
eşitliği ilkesini dahil edecek ve bu
ülkenin uygulamada gerçekleştirilmesini
temin edeceklerdir Yerine göre
yaptırımların uygulanması yıl da dahil
olmak üzere kadınlara karşı ayrımcılığın
yasaklayacak lardır kadınlara karşı
ayrımcılık yapan Yasa ve uygulamalar
yürürlükten kaldırılacak lardır taraflar
bu sözleşme hükümlerinin Özellikle de
mağdurların haklarını korumaya yönelik
tedbirlerin ki bakın burası çok önemli
cinsiyet toplumsal cinsiyet ırk renk dil
din siyasi veya başka tür görüş ulusal
veya sosyal köken bir ulusal adamı da
bağlantılı olma mülk doğum cinsel yönü
bir toplumsal cinsiyet kimliği sağlık
durumu engellilik medeni hali göçmen ve
bu veya başka bir statü gibi Herhangi
bir temele dayalı olarak ayrımcılık
yapılmaksızın uygulanmasını temin
edeceklerdir bir kadınların toplumsal
cinsiyete dayalı şiddete karşı korunması
için gerekli olan özel tedbirler bu
sözleşme hükümlerince ayrımcılık olarak
sayılmayacaktır bu sadece maddelerinden
biri bir diğer maddelerde gerçekten çok
önemli şeyler anlatıyor O zaman ben
sözleşmeyi Ben konuşmamı sonra bitirmek
istiyorum İstanbul sözleşmesi gerçekten
çok önemli kadınların kendilerini ifade
edebilmeleri vermekte yürüyebilmelerinin
erkeklerle birlikte yürüyebilmelerinin
çok değerli lütfen erkekler bizim
yanımızda olun İzmir birlikte yürüyorum
çocuklarımızı böyle yetiştirelim ve
İstanbul sözleşmesinin uygulanmasını
için gerekli olan mücadeleyi verelim
İstanbul sözleşmesi yaşatır Bu biraz
önce Saygın bir sürü kadınlar bir
bu etkileyen katılırız hala failleri
bulunamayan mahkum edilmeyen iyi halden
ceza indirimi yapılan Eğer bu sözleşme
uygulanırsa gerçekten caydırıcı bir
takım kararlar alınırsa devlet
tarafından biz kendimizi daha iyi
koruyabiliriz Çok teşekkür ediyorum bu
konuşmak için Umarım bir parça size diye
bilmişimdir İyi çalışmalar diliyorum